but that but then put them ranch doritos
oh remember when they came out those
cool ranchers
you remember that yeah i remember when
the commercial like the commercials for
[ __ ] was just way
different both like when bo jackson was
playing two sports dion sanders playing
two sports and
mike tyson and when uh when the the the
double decker taco and you had the
double decker taco sideways neck yeah i
remember that he got stuck
eating it shaq would have sideways and
that he couldn't eat he couldn't play
basketball he's shooting free though
yeah
dude remember how good remember remember
when cool rants through this remember
because for 20 years it was just doritos
cheese only regular nothing fancy you
saw them cool ranch
and then suddenly there wasn't just
ranch it was cool right
damn and it felt good on you everybody
wanted the cool ramp oh
dude they were sold out they didn't have
them everywhere i remember biking
all around town we heard that they had
them somewhere dude a friend of mine got
hit by a trans am on his bike
looking for cool ranchos brah and was on
a in a [ __ ] wheelchair
hush pup what are they called slush
puppies slush puppies and cool ranch
doritos
and they didn't go in there what what
what did you used to
a regular summer day as a kid how like
what what kind of
like you go to the gas station how where
did you get your money first of all
okay first of all we got the money was
my mom had a chart if you were good you
started out with a dollar at the
beginning of the week okay
and you got checks on there when you
were bad so everybody got checks and you
ended up at about 20 cents
my little sister though she was always
sick so she got all her money because
she couldn't do anything bad she was ill
so then we would get her money too me
and my brother would take borrow her
money from her
right and break each other off 50 cents
each so i'd roll out
about 60 cents over to that 7-eleven
i'd get myself [ __ ] two packs of
garbage pail kid cards bro you know what
i'm saying because i have a [ __ ]
stunt around my boys
remember that lugi larry oh yeah and he
had just [ __ ]
coming out of him snotty scotty oh yeah
remember bomb tom and his head atomic
atomic
adam atomic atomic adam
adam yeah dude they had uh
the twisted sisters and they were like
two snakes twirling
yeah they had um oh they had flat pat
and it was just a dude getting
steamrolled
yeah yeah yeah they had um
uh trim tim and he was getting that
[ __ ] tight haircut yeah he was
getting a haircut with the scissors like
went through his
cut his ear and cut his neck yeah um
who else did they have over uh razer
raul
yeah first fantasy guy it was like it
was back when it was slicing
yeah and he cut his wrist or something
bro and then it captured
that side with sideways for attention
horizontally to get the job done
like all right well i didn't know what
that meant when i was eight like
these cars yeah by 11 i was like okay
yeah
yeah it discontinued yeah some were a
little dark like
yeah kill yourself randall and you're
like wait those don't even rhyme but
they don't
even have this they don't even start
with the he's just hanging in a closet
you know you're like damn this [ __ ] is
dark
quaalude [ __ ] donald damn and he just
have a couple pills and his kids are
[ __ ] crying by the cops
ghostly george he was just hanging
himself
hangman hank he was just like he was
hanging himself in front of the students
he was a substitute teacher like
damn first day just got a degree
i would get that and they had a fireball
bruh and that was the thing if you
wanted to flex a little bit in front of
your boys
or to check something a little bit you
wanted to get that fireball show up with
that red that lusciousness kind of
and have that heat in your mouth man and
that was about you could just stick it
inside you know just
see how long it would burn and they knew
you could [ __ ] if you had that piece in
there
and you get that that thing was about a
nickel and you put that thing in your
jaw and show up man
so i would do that and then if i had a
little bit extra money then i would get
myself maybe a chocolate for at night
getting myself a kitkat
and they have four pieces in there
sometimes i would get my mama um
payday candy bar and that was kind of
like a nice candy bar they had back then
right now it's a nature zone they got
all these fancy ones but back then they
had that payday and it was for
smart people right but it was different
man what would you get if you think of
you
well i i would first i had this little
bronze like glass
like little jar and i wait till i fill
it up but i sell
i sell lemonade oh wow well yeah me and
my sister we sell them for like
10 cents five cents whatever whatever
you have
until it fills up the jar so i just go
back in and keep making it i just wanted
to fill that job
and how many you sell a quartz gallons
cup i'd sell it until it was gone yeah
i'd keep going back and make some more
if i need to i wanted to fill that jar
up
yeah that's i sold three cents
as long as it's filled up so then you
got you know you got to fill it up yeah
yeah that's that feeling then you roll
it down you're going to put it and go
pull up it
then then you got you take that jar just
shove it in my pocket that's a lot of
money right now go
to the public pool just hang out see
what's going on over there
because that was on the way because then
he turned and you go down and there was
a circle k
okay so i don't but it wasn't on the
street it was in it right at the end of
the neighborhood so i didn't have to
cross the street so
it was dangerous right so now what was
happening at the public pool
probably like just kids running around
screaming there was a diving board
the hot the hot girl lived behind it oh
she was
she's had bleach blonde hair oh yeah
coley sanders
was she japanese or was she yeah she was
like occasional oh yeah you can't even
say white these days
yeah you can get hog tied and and
stripped of all your medals if you say
color yeah so she was all of uh
norwegian nordic descent
right you'd have to ask her what she is
yeah yeah exactly
i don't even know well i get sued for
even mentioning a human
i think that's how it works these days
so yeah then
there's a diving board i can just hear
it now
you know and there's the deep end yeah
there's the deep end and then they're
just whistles blowing right and left
yeah stop
stop breathing yeah yeah stop breathing
yeah
you're you know what i mean
and then you're breathing underwater
stop right so you can't i'll close you
close your eyes under water yeah stop
drowning they would say yeah there was
the outdoor shower
yeah people some family would be in the
corner with their little picnic set up
yeah they have a setup right
kind of by the lifeguard so you didn't
[ __ ] with them yeah yeah and then the
older kids down by the diving board
lining up
and if you were if you weren't tall
enough you couldn't you couldn't
even go on the dive board in the deep
end then there's adult swim
yeah and i go adult swim and then i'll
wait for adult swimming now to go take
off to the gas station because that's
when what the kids had to get out you
got to get out and then go to the
playground and they'd walk around
go play the ouija board in the bathroom
adults only yeah yeah
they go seven seven seven minutes of
heaven over there by the
by the tricycles yeah man yeah you had
to get out
yeah so i take off to the gas station
they they had the
the jolly rancher fire the fire jolly
ranchers
they were called fire flavored they were
cinnamon but they were crazy hot
and the package would be stuck to the
sides but it was molted around so like
it was there was angles geo geometry
angles on the thing because it
had melted and they it's been sitting in
the sun yeah so you didn't know you know
how to get into that snack you get some
little banana laffy taffys they didn't
even have jokes on them back in the day
wow you just had to watch just think of
something happening you had to open and
just
make up a joke or something hey what do
apples say on their birthday
i don't know just give me one no what
apple say on the birthday
oh dude what yeah that uh
forest fires are for are for friendly
yeah yeah yeah
all right yeah so
those and then uh you get those little
it was like it looked like a barrel
mm-hmm it was a but it tastes like a
melted popsicle it was
like a little blue juice you ever seen
those yeah it was wax
no no no i'm talking about yeah well the
carton was yes it's like a little it's
like a barrel and it had a little metal
topping yep you peel that off
yeah oh that [ __ ] was good what was that
it's
melted popsicles all the melted
popsicles that go in
in the stores and they just put them in
the that oh i didn't even know
i didn't i didn't know it either dang
man that's behind the scenes yeah it has
a it had a kick in the back
yeah that [ __ ] get your neck on i
don't know what it was it's a free neck
brace man i'm [ __ ] loosen you up yeah
that's
you that in a double decker taco
oh yeah tacos that's her i know
but dude people used to um you're at the
nurse's office oh yeah
do you remember the nurse yeah i knew
kids who used to go to the
nurse's office just to switch clothes
with the lost and found just to get a
new pair of pants
that pink pants are bruh they had to do
they pinched their pants on purse
bruh and that's back when i remember
dude i remember i get a boner right and
go into the lady and be like hey there's
something wrong with my dick
yeah check this out yeah yeah check this
out my dick keep getting hearts a bee
stung me that's what i would tell her
yeah what'd the nurse say i think she
liked me a little bit but i was young
and how was she she was probably maybe
50 or 48 but her husband had left her
and she had a kid that was in her class
oh she can't send you a note and be like
hey yeah i think i need to check up on
deal
yeah still sick today sometimes i would
get a note
i think steel's sick yeah he seems
really sick today
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one